hey this is presh talwalkar
i found this neat puzzle on the internet
imagine a rectangular grid of circles
we'll color in some of the circles with
blue dots to make a mathematical
equation
it currently reads
the quantity 71 plus 1
times the quantity 71 minus 1 is equal
to 71
but this is not a correct
equation the puzzle is to either color
one blue dot or erase one blue dot to
make a valid equation
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we make this a valid equation
the surprising answer
is that in the very last digit of 1
erase the second blue dot from the
bottom
the left hand side of this equation
evaluates to the quantity 71 plus 1
times the quantity 71 minus 1 which
equals 72 times 70 which equals 5040.
the right hand side evaluates to 7
factorial the 1 becomes an exclamation
point which is a factorial so we take
the product of 1 to 7
and we get
5040
and that's how we get a valid equation
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video i post
math videos that can be watched for free
with topics from people around the world
because math is universal
if you'd like to help the cause please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos
watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos
and email me a puzzle or math topic at
presh and mindyourdecisions.com
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are linked in the video
description and if you so choose you can
support this cause financially on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support